he's like you know what let's play this whole
thing out dude let's play this whole thing out
so i can make him feel like he has a chance just
so i can take it all away from him at the very end
this is cyberbullying and here we go so
we have a game we have the london system
yes and knight c6 another guy who's going for
this knight c6 they got to start moving that c bun
that's what they got yeah so i i think again myth
is playing playing sort of the opening setup that
i recommended to um uh xqc yesterday i think it's
pretty reasonable um but we're but already myth is
thinking so he's kind of channeling his inner
xqc and thinking here very early in the game
um but he has to have been ready for the london
system because pokeman has played this i believe
every single game so far how he plays queen
b5 good move yeah very good move by myth
beautifully hits b2 and that stops white from
castling now pokey seems like a cis like a
system player she really likes to get kind of a
nice comfortable position that she that she can
mess around in and make things happen but she's
already dealing with some very serious threats
and we got queen b2 by the way so pokey plays
knight v5 man this is going to get removed
from pokemon really really good this could
get really bad really quickly because myth
doesn't have a check they're both
covered he gonna play knight c3 oh my god
i mean i don't know what he's gonna do here but
yeah we'll see very very soon we'll see he might
play rook c8 i mean he might just see knight c7
and just play rook to c8 that also could happen
i really want to know on uh
he's clicking around he sees
he saw e6 which by the way might be like some sort
of brilliant sacrifice crazy attack maybe yeah
oh don't go back to b5 knight cc oh that
would be no no don't go to b5 don't go back
could go to b7 true true
oh good move by myth good move once pokemon
castles are king myth is in very bad shape
because it's very hard to develop that being
said e6 here would would actually trap the
white knight and then it's gonna be very hard
for pokemon to respond here what does she have
to play like rugby one or knight c4 sometimes uh
i think probably c4 and go for queen a4 although
queen b5 unfortunately now allows c4 immediately
because the knight protects c4 if pokeman finds
c4 i think she's well on her way to a victory he
doesn't see this looks very scary very very scary
um okay yeah she could go here no my my king takes
it actually never mind i'm trolling um but the
rook don't forget about the rook my rook is under
threat not good because of that move she just made
nice to move the rook over
now if pokemon says queen a4 she's going to win
as well to trade off some rooks and go down to
the end of the board yes this is actually an
insane position because white is only up a pawn
but it's plus nine because of how weak the king
is rook b1 like hikaru said or look for the check
don't go queen c6 do not trade queens do not try
and even then maybe you're still going to win but
don't trade queens so queen yeah i think rook b1
and queen a4 both moves are very cleanly winning
here um i think rook v1 is actually a very natural
move to play here i think it's a very natural
move to to try and create checkmates also i
know pokemon likes likes the background checkmate
theme so i can see rook b1 and she can see like
oh no no oh that's a huge mistake i mean i think
she's still going to win the game but that is a
huge mistake by pokeman but myth is clicking his
king like he's clicking his king he he he doesn't
even see backward backward queen right now oh wait
no no he just saw it he just clicked this queen
these guys are terrifying me with their clicking
you just look at his screen right now it's it's a
no but he sees that the bishop guards the queen is
he going to trade oh he played oh oh oh oh no oh
oh no no no no oh no oh he saw that he was
guarded but he didn't and look at pokeman
oh my gosh
she is taking her time i don't think she's gonna
miss it one thing that pokeman has been really
good at is checkmating pattern she's done a lot
of puzzles and i do think she's gonna see it
the only reason she might not see this she
might see the fork with knight takes pawn
and just trade the queen yes she might
play queen to and no no no no just no
clean i really like her
have that [ __ ] that hurts
oh my god i knew i should have just taken it dude
now pokemon finds knight takes d4 here i'm
gonna be ridiculous trust yeah knight d4 is
crazy having said that hikaru if she scans for
captures it's the only capture she has and then
she has to find knight f3 true true well i mean i
think that's why chess is that's also why chess is
such a great game because you have that learning
curve and it's such a long process i think in many
ways it teaches you how to learn and how kind of
how to lose and how to persevere and overcome it
and um sort of find that motivation within
yourself and i think xqc oh no oh no no no no
no what does she think of three yeah i know when
pokeman sees that you can just tell the way she
put her fingers together that was also another
tale telltale sign you can tell that you could
tell something was wrong with that yeah i i wish
i was uh oh just just that expression you could
tell she sensed that something was wrong there
and again pokemon with the obvious tell you can
you can see how she's looking she's like what
is what's going on here what is the idea and
unfortunately because it's such a weird move i
think it's pretty obvious what the idea is on h7
okay well she blunders it okay it's still
winning for pokemane yeah wow that's actually
lucky i mean if she had moved the other
rook over it would have been mate like yeah
damn she's gotta go here unfortunately the
white king is still too open here so pokeman
should find a checkmate um but that being said
at least smith gets something and i think come on
you go straight ahead go take
it oh you want another one
i like it yeah would you look at that as two i
could play this game too take the rook come on
all right come on don't take the pawn there's
a rook on the other side i like queen h4 just
for the yes just for the idea of making a
check and hoping that pokemon won't see it
uh to be honest don't touch your rook
no don't touch your rook please don't
touch the rook on a1 please just move your queen
yeah he's um okay good he finally sees it so
i actually could see he actually clicked on
the rook on a1 when he was almost like going
to play rook d1 so at least he takes the rook
i don't know if she if she's lucky or brilliant
but queen d8 is made if the knight isn't there
so exactly yep oh wait like walking on
on a tightrope and like if she moves
the night now thinking it's hanging
if she does not look at queenie two
just looking if she doesn't look for checks
it's very very dangerous it's it's it isn't
she mated on queen season like king of but maybe
not almost almost definitely very very close here
oh yeah okay dude she this is terrifying like
yeah it's almost like there's no checkmate
because white would need to get the queen to
g5 oh my gosh pokemon it's just cokey still
it's not checkmate still i know king e4 is still
not made but you don't go forward oh my it's wait
what how is it a draw exactly there's probably
some repetition here with like queen c4 queen c3
c4 you can check on c4 c3 and f5 you go f7 c4 you
do the yoyo oh yo yo between f7 c4 and c4 c3 it's
just a classic yo-yo and it's like the yo-yo where
you uh what do you call it i don't know what you
call where did that even come from yo-yo around
the moon i don't know anyway whatever um it just
said yo-yo yeah because it's a yo-yo you see it's
like one end up back i know yeah it's not like
you're right i used to play the yo-yo but i don't
know what you call that that anyway whatever okay
is that an xqc thing or you just made that up
i just made that all back beautiful beautiful
we just witnessed history you are the first grand
master to ever call a maneuver like that a yo-yo
so it's uh but myth takes mitt doesn't realize
that he's in grave danger the scissor or the
ladder sorry check on g2 and go queen h1 yeah
um it's time for essentially g1 also yeah
you see is it
oh wait all the ambulance okay why'd you
you got us all the way over here for this
well she she really got my hopes up you know that
i that's so disrespectful dude that is so rude
she really did she really she's like you know what
let's play this whole thing out dude let's play
this whole thing out so i can make him feel like
he has a chance just so i can take it all away
from him at the very end this is cyberbullying
i can't believe it
i know i know it's me
oh i was sweating at the end there i won't
lie uh pokey how uh how did that match go
expectations versus reality how was that um
to be honest i have not been practicing
enough chess and my chest vision was
quite off today that's why i had to
keep putting on the goggles um yes
that was trash talk we thought you
were like we thought you were like zero
oh no no no that's me like looking for the right
move you know that's what i was missing yeah
i'll watch my goggles next time don't worry thanks
but yeah i think it went i mean i'm glad i won
but myth has been practicing pretty well he could
have taken it for sure but you know i got like 200
rating on him so i need to win right that's the
expectation i mean yeah we've had uh we've had all
sorts of crazy matches so rating hasn't always but
yes i mean i guess going in uh you would be the
favorite myth um we speaking of you know favorites
we were saying you were in the group of death in
the group in the early stage right like did you
feel that way how did that how's your chest been
since you kind of kicked this whole process
off in january uh up to now the group of the
group of death yeah we thought that it was kind of
insane with sardosh and benji and um overall like
i've just been having a great time playing chess i
don't think i've put in as much time as i would uh
have liked to overall there's a lot of things
to work on and to uh for me to do but overall
like i think this has been a really great
introduction to chess and i'm excited to like
keep at it you know and i think that's the
important thing that i'm getting out of this
is like you know i've become interested in this
game because of this event and because of you know
just the excitement around versing some of you
know some people like pokey and and nico and benji
and just the hype all around it so i definitely
want to you know move forward with it which i
think yeah that's that's important for me newbie
group next time and it's me and myth in it yup
straight to the top yeah but uh no yeah for sure
this is it's been extremely like motivating and
even like playing against these like i guess
like the juggernaut players in the group
and still being able to like you know make some
things happen or it being like me just not seeing
one move to it being like a really really close
match or like me getting even ahead just off
of missing one move is really like obviously it
could be really the motivating but it's something
to learn from and it's uh it's motivating also in
the same exact way so i want to keep it up well um
thank you to you both of you for the match
uh myth hope to see you playing chess on
stream in the future and pokey will see
you for the semis thank you for having us
you